just in time for virus comes the perfect
film showing the importance of social
distancing yes Netflix is the platform
or as I like to call it vertical
snowpiercer is a uniquely wild horror
film that makes me thankful I'm not
fighting over toilet paper in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
film's cryptic ending and what exactly
it was trying to say about our society
hint it's not good
so grab something to eat because here we
go welcome to floor zero the top floor
of an over 300 plus level structure
known affectionately as the hole it's
here that a selection of meticulously
prepared meals are cooked for the
exactly 666 guests yes 666 if that is an
assign the hole isn't the friendliest of
places we know this is the number since
at the end of the film we see the final
floor is 333 and there are two people
per floor meet goring our film's
protagonist who wakes up on level 48 but
notice before he wakes he hears his
cellmate say the following over darkness
[Music]
this is actually the first line in the
entire film and it's arguably the most
important there are those at the top who
are content with the way things are
those at the bottom who want change but
lack the means to do so and those who
fall this last line that those who fall
actually has two meanings first the
actual people who fall over the legend
die and secondly people like goring and
his future cellmate Ballarat who
willingly descend in order to create
change so what this quote really means
is that these three types of people are
those who don't want to change those who
want to but can't do it and those who
risk everything even death to change it
Goering spends much of the first-act
figuring out how this place operates
just like we the viewer do and in so
doing we create a subconscious bond with
him even asking ourselves what would we
do if we were in that situation to make
matters worse gorings platform mate is a
greedy old man by the name of trim
Agassi a man who unlike Goering is a
prisoner for having thrown his TV out
the window and accidentally murdering
someone they gave him the option of
either spending his time at the psych
hospital or spending a year in the hole
goring on the other hand is here
voluntarily
he tells from Agassi that he's here for
six months in exchange for a college
diploma and thought this would be a good
way to quit smoking it's important to
note here that those on the outside
don't really know what goes on in the
hole even the character immigrant Arry
who interviewed candidates for the hole
didn't exactly know what went on there
what's important here is that the hole
promises a prize for those who endure it
for amou quinary it's the cure for her
cancer through magazi his freedom and
goring his diploma these for the most
part are empty promises since most died
before they're done their time but it's
the analogy to capitalism and its
promise that if you work hard you can
get what you dream of that also falls
flat
many believe in capitalism but are held
back by a system which is cruel and
unjust just like the hold but they cling
to the hope that things will get better
as the McGary says later things won't
change unless there is a spontaneous
solidarity but we'll get to what that
means in a bit every day a platform
descends containing a myriad of food and
depending
which level you're on the amount the
food is also dictated by the Preferences
of those in the hole for example one of
the interview questions Goering is asked
is what his favorite food is later on
we'll see escargot is on the platform
which is what he chose as the platform
descends deeper and deeper less food is
available for those at the bottom until
around level a hundred where there's
almost no food at all leaving over 400
people to starve who have to make
drastic decisions such as eating their
partners while the platform is there
however the prisoners are given one
minute to stuff themselves as much as
possible before it descends to the next
level
if anyone hoards food extreme heat or
cold fills the level killing the
inhabitants until the food is put back
3m Agassi tells Goering that because
they're on level 47 94 people have eaten
before them he's almost done his time
and notes that every month the prisoners
are randomly placed on a new level three
magazi has been as high as level 8 and
as low as a hundred and thirty-two each
prisoner is also allowed one item on
their journey Goering is laughed at
since he brings a copy of Don Quixote a
instead of something practical like
three Maga C's knife not only does
Goering resemble Don Quixote but his
journey within the platform mimics the
thematic journey of Quixote as well the
book was revolutionary for its time in
the way it emphasized the disparities
between class and worth the aristocrats
were seen as thoughtless unkind and
frivolous while the peasant Sancho wise
and thoughtful we see this system play
out in the film through the greed of
those at the top contrasted with
characters like Goering whose
thoughtfulness forces him to act for the
good of the whole
having Goering paired with three magazi
shows how individual greed reinforces a
corrupt system the first thing Goering
mentions is that they should ration the
food so that those below can have enough
three magazi being the complete foil to
Goering responds by pissing on the
people below him instead of helping
those at the bottom people in this movie
get literally pissed and [ __ ] on I can't
show that clip much like how many
billionaires and corporations exploit
piss and [ __ ] metaphorically of course
on the poor things begin to change with
the introduction of Miharu a woman who
descends on the platform in her search
for her child
the Japanese translation of Miharu is to
open one's
eyes wide and it's through her struggle
that Goering opens his eyes to the
injustice perpetrated by this system in
fact to accentuate this point Miharu
doesn't even speak the end of Act one
puts Goering in a tough situation a full
month has passed and he awakens tied up
on a new floor level 171 this means
almost certain death for the two men so
three magazi being a veteran has tied
goring and will feast on him slowly and
even feed Goering his own flesh in order
to survive Fortuna Maga see this is a
perfectly normal and rational thing to
do given the situation he justifies it
by saying it's not him who's doing these
crimes but the people above him the
system has forced him to do something
drastic in order to survive much like
how many people in the real world do
illegal things in order to survive as
well and as three magazi cuts into his
first piece of gorings flesh he's saved
by Miharu
only to wake up next month on level 33
with a new partner
this is amol query she's an idealist
like goring but lacks the fire it takes
to actually create change she spends
weeks yelling at the people below her
pleading with them to ration so there
will be food left for those below peace
please fall on deaf ears until goring
threatens to [ __ ] on their food since a
Moog we're used to work for the
administration the company that runs the
vertical self-management Center aka the
hole she has some inside information no
one under 16 is allowed there and she
believes she knows why the system is
there to begin with it's a test to see
what it takes to create a revolution of
change a change that will be the result
of what she calls quote a spontaneous
sense of solidarity of course scoring
retorts even going so far as to
conjecture
so we have Easton about everything does
it belong it up or not I'm aware he's
item her pet ramses ii is named after
the greatest Egyptian pharaoh of the new
kingdom the dog's death later in the
film symbolic of the death of greatness
the death of the idea that we can unite
everyone under one strong banner a month
passes and Goering awakens to find that
T Mallory has killed herself after
finding out they've been placed on level
202 basically a death sentence
no food makes it this far down he has to
eat pages of his book as well as her
body in order to stay alive eventually
making it to his final month with a new
platform mate named baharat baharata is
smart and brought a rope as his item
believing that if he could just make it
close to the top he could escape but
this plan implies that those at the top
are willing to help and that is
definitely not the case with the people
above him literally [ __ ] on him as
he attempts to climb goring and baharat
devise a plan to descend along with the
platform and evenly distribute the food
themselves even going so far as to
withhold food from the people in the
first 50 levels so that those at the
bottom can have their fair share they
even mercilessly beat those who try to
take any food from them it isn't until
they descend and meet someone who is
only known as the wise old man that
they're told the only way they can make
real lasting change is with a symbol in
this case a message if a message can
make it all the way to level zero maybe
even those cooks up there will
understand what is happening below and
what perfect message then panna cotta
well it's not so much the panna cotta
but the defiant act of leaving a dish
untouched but as will later find there's
an even better message as they descend
to the final level goring saves Mihara
from an attacker just like she saved him
earlier she doesn't make it but he finds
something more valuable a small child
the thing mahara was searching for all
along he Mowgli told us that mehar own
ever had a child and that people under
16 can't be put in a hole so this means
that a that child is simply a symbol for
change or be is real and that the
administration is into some real effed
up [ __ ] that will then cause change by
Herat and Goran give the child to panna
cotta in what is a selfless act
contradicting the greed we've seen
throughout the film baharat succumbs to
his wounds leaving Goran to take the
child to the final
level he's realized that the child is
the message after all he also quotes Don
Quixote here to hammer home the notion
that wealth is not measured by what you
own but by how you spend it partially I
know that I think it has nothing they
touch often is not seen on hostel as you
know let's come on get out see that
because that the spending it well here
is referring to spending it on others
sharing it if you will
he places the child on the platform and
it ascends to the top a film that
started at level zero ends at the bottom
only to come full circle to the top now
we don't see what happens to goring but
we can assume just like how Don Quixote
dies at the end of the book so too does
goring Don Quixote's death signals the
end of an arrow the end of knights and
chivalry and in gorings the end of the
corrupt and greedy nature of the whole
the child is the spark the message if
you will that will change the system and
call people to action
it will unify people to work together
toward a common goal and break the
complacency that prevents change the
platform isn't just a horror film with a
unique premise it's one that asks tough
philosophical questions about how we
function as a society so I leave it up
to you if you were in the hole what
would you do and more importantly what
would you order thanks for watching
everyone please make sure to give the
video a like and subscribe with that
fell on to get notified as soon as one
of my videos comes out I would love to
hear your thoughts about this movie
below and come and follow me on Twitter
at big story whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much